what else you got nick uh cats music
original songs we haven't done it for a
couple weeks
uh but this is american idol
i'm sad
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i mean and talented
[Music]
oh my gosh wow that was fantastic
i know i love that lady that was great
shouts out that made my day oh that was
great last picture
damn who is that hey i gotta find her
name oh [ __ ] great
do you like the hisses and street
pockets
bruh i pictured it in my head yeah
that's what you're supposed to do
okay
and also an underrated tactic too
[Laughter]
like something scares the [ __ ] out of me
is he [ __ ] hissing
[Music]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that video was
great
looks like he slaps his
wow man that girl is amazing bro that
was fantastic
yeah let me get her name really quick oh
man
damn so funny
shout out the culture corner
she's like jewels she reminds me of
jewel a little bit yeah her voice was
pleasant dude i remember jewel bro ooh
she's got dope ass songs
oh when jewel came out man i remember
you had them
danglers out the front bro oh what do
you mean oh she's talking about her
teeth
no no no her teeth were it kind of made
her
more attractive i thought the flaws in
her teeth were cool she didn't get them
fixed for you yeah she won't get because
uh
someone with the singing i think she was
oh really she's worried about dude
what do you mean i'm talking about them
tits oh at the front
and then the messed up teeth and the
beautiful voices how would you even do
this this looks like the guitar
pictures of people's tits back then who
was it nick do we know yeah that was
faustina
co-written by uh aaron from brooklyn new
york oh
shout out to brooklyn faustina brooklyn
wow what's this guy on a loan or what's
going on here
jewel was it man and here we go the bad
guy from hook right here right here
i was on my grandma and grandpa's farm
and the king and the sting crew was
there
and as i recall the dream went a little
something like this look at this
king in the guitar brandon got stung
theo is the rat king
i love cat and champion
i think i'm gonna watch me some king in
the sting yeah wow in the kitchen
granny's cookie jar me and theo honky
talking on grandpa's guitar
chapelle on a skateboard he was doing
backflips
yeah nick was loading up them videos
[Music]
on the countryside i'll give cat my ring
brandon got stung to you
[Laughter]
keep me satisfied
i think i'm going to watch a little king
in the sting
branding god's stone for you is a rat
king i love cat
damn chin you can sing boy
things i'm gonna watch be some king in
the sting man i gotta
[Music]
that should be our theme song
dude that's a theme song i love it i
love that song that was good
guys i'm here in indonesia
oh [ __ ] i got stuck here on the
quarantine
we're having a ball out here my name's
earl
just uh say i love the show and what a
cool dude
uh-huh you know gang gang buzz buzz guys
have a good one
wow dude he literally looks like one
handsomer when he picks the camera up
too huh
it's tough when you're doing that yeah
yeah
i i was like i had no idea he's such a
beautiful young man
dude he literally looks like one of the
guitars from corn yeah he does
or kyle knew it yeah like brian welch
you mean brian wells yeah yeah he looks
just like him from foreign and healthier
yeah a little happier i think um wow i
mean i could listen that song all
goddamn i know yeah that was a good
thing
definitely obviously a proposal to cat
basically was with the underlying tone i
got out of it nick what do you think
he shot his shot from indonesia this
guy's great they're
i love both these songs but i think the
third one that we got might be the best
there's
one there's a better one than these two
yeah i can't even imagine
i don't know i've been holding my penis
for both the two songs
i'll let it go now i keep holding it
keep holding it all right
get tighter okay this might be the same
guy with a different haircut
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
jesus christ
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow wow
jesus man
[Music]
boy this wow those music videos make me
feel like we're doing something right
god damn those are frozen yeah and what
we'd love to do is we'd love to put
together we're going to put a thing on
to the new website
um which is cat's pie k-a-t-s-p-o-d
you can go there now we're going to put
a page on there where you can get an
album that has all the songs
and the proceeds will go to the people
that
the creators uh nick we can do that yeah
we can make that happen
um that's awesome yeah man that's
awesome man those are
so good and that that was uh mr phil
brick
mr phil brick wow they're all so good
they're so good all three of them were
so good sorry matt philbrick my bad
thanks matt uh yeah it makes me feel
almost just ashamed that anybody would
do
something that nice for us pretty cool
yeah it feels like we're doing
something right well that's not it
at least some people are watching you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah no it's
not and they're giving back to us
you know yeah yeah so talented those are
sure
those made me happy
is